okay today's topic now preacher's not
here right now because he's out living
his best life he's traveling at the
moment uh so i figured i would just do
this real quick and then if there's
follow-ups to be done we will as far as
the verdict goes
people really kept asking me about my
thoughts about the trump now the verdict
is in
the defender will rise to face the jury
and hearken to its verdicts
dave wisconsin versus kyle wright
that's the first count of the
information joseph rosenbaum read the
jury find the defendant kyle h
rittenhouse not guilty
as to the second count of the
information richard mcginnis we the jury
find the defendant kyle h riddenhaus not
guilty
as to the third count of the information
unknown mail we the jury find the
defendant kyle h rittenhouse not guilty
as to the fourth count of the
information anthony huber we the jury
find the defendant kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty
as to the fifth count of the information
gage rose courts we the jury find the
defendant kyle edward kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty
members of the jury are these your
unanimous verdicts
is there anyone who does not agree with
the verdict as read
would you wish the jury pulled
okay
uh okay folks your job is done and
we started
just about three weeks ago
and i uh
i told you it could last
two weeks and two days this is two weeks
this is three weeks
you were a wonderful jury to work with
you were punctual you were attentive
it is what i expected to happen
all they really have to do in this case
is get reasonable doubt and if you
looked at all the facts of the case you
watch the video footage the testimonies
i mean the moment the guy got up on the
stand and said listen he only shot me
when i pointed his my gun at him
it's like breath now the state claimed
that gross kreutz did not pose a threat
to rittenhouse when he confronted him in
the street that he even had his hands up
at one point but he did have a pistol in
one of those hands and the state at the
defense rather proved that
got gross kroitz to admit that
rittenhouse did not fire at him until he
lowered his hands and pointed the gun
that sounded like gunshots gage
grosskroyd's heard the first shooting
sounds like multiple gunshots and
shortly after he became a part of the
second shooting scene you shot somebody
who's shot
eyewitness video from the scene shows as
more people approached kyle rittenhouse
he was knocked to the ground gross croix
was roughly five feet away with his
glock pistol in his right hand and his
cell phone in his left at first his
hands were raised
what was going through your mind at this
particular moment
that i was going to die but on
cross-examination the defense went
through the video again at times second
by second when you were standing three
to five feet from him with your arms up
in the air
he never fired right
correct it wasn't until you pointed your
gun at him advanced on him with your gun
now your hands down pointed at him
that he fired right
correct
there was an abundance
of reasonable doubt involved in this and
so for me watching the case unfold
looking at the testimonies i'm like yeah
this is what i expected to happen and
once the jury took more than a day
to come back from deliberations in my
mind it was pretty clear that he was
going to get off
because when your goal is reasonable
doubt and the jury's taking that long
deliberation clearly there's a lot of
doubt cementing they're asking a bunch
of questions so just from my personal
anecdotal experience watching high
profile case when it takes a long long
time
generally the person's going to be
going free on the most serious charges
and in this case he was acquitted of all
charges um
now
people ask me do i think he should be
guilty
from a legal standpoint no not at all
watching the details of the case i'm not
gonna i don't think so from a moral
standpoint i think it's a bit different
you can look at his behavior as uh
reckless extremely dangerous
antagonizing you can look at it a lot of
different ways and i'm not gonna lecture
to everybody about what they should or
shouldn't think about that what i do
think is really unfortunate me watching
this from afar and paying attention to
this is how
everybody frames this from a political
angle right if you're left-leaning he's
a vigilante stalker killer dangerous
person and if you're right leaning a lot
of people say he's a [ __ ] heroes i
brought
can we can we slot it in between you
know what i'm saying can we find a bit
of a middle ground without having to
politicize the whole thing um because it
feels as though
when people go through these lengths to
misrepresent the facts
of what happened to characterize this
person and things that are not yet
justified they
rile people up it gets people very
aggravated people get their pitchforks
they put their lines in the sand and
they and they pick their team and so
based off whatever team you are he's
either guilty or innocent rather than
just looking at what actually happened
um
and i think that's the most unfortunate
part for me watching this it made me
think of that case a while back
where
a cop was called and this girl was
trying to like stab somebody else and
the cop shot the young black woman and
then everybody lost their minds and i'm
like
but that's what the cop is supposed to
do
if someone's brandishing a knife
look this is just me if it's my daughter
okay and she's about to get stabbed you
best believe i want the cop to shoot the
person who's about to stab her
but people have like this anti-police
slant so hard that they all logic just
goes out the window when it comes to
these kind of things and for me watching
it's just unfortunate because i'm like
bruh you know damn well if it's your
daughter in that situation or your
family member who's about to get stabbed
you want the police officer to act you
feeling me so
that's what i think this case
demonstrated like the particulars of the
case are not that interesting once you
realize a certain set of effects you're
like all right well this is pretty
obviously going to be self-defense like
you know there's nothing that can really
convince me that beyond a reasonable
doubt that this man is guilty right so
that part didn't it means everything
surrounding it like the media
is pressure and like just individuals
just getting on top and be like white
supremacy was like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
so
now dude all the riling up i'm i'm
i don't know if there's gonna be more
rights and more looting or burning and
if there is like
you know at some point maybe this is
just me we have to find a better way to
deal with this stuff rather than just
burning the local
mom and pop shops in the local spots
around like i don't know to me just
doesn't seem sensible to continuously do
that someone asked me to they said abba
do you think he was fake crying
i mean that man is an ugly crier and so
if he faked that his acting skills at 17
are superb
but again
it feels like people want to
characterize everything based off of
where they lean politically
if you went online right and you went to
any media celebrity who commented on
this or any youtube personality if you
just looked at how they leaned
politically that was going to infer
what they thought the verdict should be
right whether or not they watched the
video whether or not they followed the
trial whether or not they watched the
witness testimonies if you just knew how
they leaned politically you knew where
they were going to say
pretty much 95 of the time i think
that's what the conversation should be
focused on because i think that's what
created all this public pressure for
this to even be prosecuted for all this
to even happen
um
and i think that's also fueling a lot of
our divide
so
i think that's pretty much summarizes my
thoughts on this i'm worried that you
know there's going to be more fires and
more violence it's going to stem from
this and
even though i think the right verdict
was rendered
the wounds that we're still dealing with
are still very much present